[Música]
o que mais valorizamos nossas vidas em
nossas vidas
a questão de valorização da vida depende
muito do lugar em que a gente nasce de
quem somos das pessoas com quem nos
relacionamos do mundo em que vivemos nos
locais que visitamos ou das páginas que
das redes sociais que nós e santos em
uma sociedade cada vez mais baseada no
consumismo
nessa sociedade contemporânea do que a
gente disse nós temos uma capacidade
muito grande em procurar cada vez mais
do que ser quando a gente olha para essa
imagem e talvez muitos de vocês já
ouviram o famoso pequeno príncipe diz a
esse pequeno garoto ele esse é instigado
a analisar quais são os personagens
existentes dentro dessa sociedade
ele observa que uma sociedade baseada em
crenças pessoais e que de certa forma
daquilo que se tem são alguns
personagens que a gente vê no nosso
cotidiano seja o rei que na sua
continuidade
ele continua a querer dar ordens sejam
vaidoso que só olha para si mesmo seja o
contador que só pensa em possuir mas que
de certa forma não sabe pra que que de
certa forma ele vai utilizar aquilo da
lei ou seja o acendedor de lampião que
cogita até uma função tão importante que
dá luz para a humanidade segue tão
ocupado na vida que na verdade não olha
para si mesmo e por fim o sábio que de
tanto saber sabe pouco a respeito de si
mesmo e quando a gente olha para
pequenos príncipes existentes em nossa
sociedade
eu gostaria de mostrar pra vocês um
garoto que esse é o enzo o excesso
quando eu tinha mais ou menos quatro
para cinco anos de idade ainda muito
pequeno não domingo à tarde naquele
domingo do sossego que todos nós
queremos nem depois de três quatro horas
da tarde
sei que aquele momento do descanso mas
quando você faz uma criança descansar
quase que impossível
nessa época o eso jogava muito joguinhos
do celular já com 45 anos e hoje nós
temos crianças com 123 anos de idade que
já têm esse certo vício ou dependência
mas a história do eso é que neste
domingo à tarde ele veio pra mim falou
cara cadê aquele celular
na verdade era um celular nessa época
andava com dois celulares assim como
muitos de nós já andamos durante muito
tempo e ele me pediu o jogo para jogar o
jogo do macaco
esse jogo do macaco uma curiosidade é
que um dia antes nós estávamos tendo uma
experiência de lhe escrever o nome dele
e naquele momento apareceu na tela do
celular para digitar o login ea senha
o fato curioso que essas crianças hoje
em dia elas são extremamente
inteligentes que ele estava copiando as
letras do meu nome no lugar da senha
para tentar me auto raqa mas na verdade
naquele momento que o desbloqueio do
celular pra ele eu não dei tanta
importância e continuei assistindo e
fazendo as atividades que estava em cima
de um outro local existe um segundo
celular para o celular do trabalho eo
celular do trabalho toda hora ficava
brisa falei poxa vida numa sociedade tão
inovadora de tanta transformação digital
será que não me chamando agora vamos
trabalhar ao domingo à tarde
eu não dei importância para aquilo pouco
tempo depois dos 40 minutos que eu pego
o celular e olha as mensagens de
faturamento
o enzo havia comprado 97 dólares de
itens para o seu macaco
nesse momento um macaco já voava o
macaco já comeu bananas especiais o
macaco já era um macaco totalmente
diferenciado e aí como que você bloqueia
uma criança dessa porque de certa forma
já nasceu com chip da digitalização
implantado mas uma coisa dá certo como
eu deveria ensinar para o eso o que que
ele deveria ser o que é que o caso
deveria
porque naquele momento ele ser o melhor
amigo brincar na rua ou ter o celular na
mão
qual seria a diferença em um certo dia
eu perguntei pra esse é o uso o que ele
gostaria de ser o exame responder uma
coisa eu gostaria de ser [ __ ]
e aí como é que se assusta com aquilo
não sabe se isso é um adjetivo se isso é
uma palavra não muito bem apropriada mas
é certo que ele já escutava isso em hash
tags né no nosso cotidiano
muita gente acha que a hashtag são
somente aquilo que é inscrito na
internet mas não são palavras que a
gente utiliza pra poder nem as pessoas
nem algum tipo de conhecimento nem
alguma cultura e neste momento como o
que explicaria proeza que para ele poder
ser [ __ ] ele deveria construir alguns
alicerces e desses alicerces
um deles que eu escolhi foi a humildade
a humildade é algo raro pois raramente
admiramos porque quando a gente fala de
humildade a gente pensa que é o oposto
da agressividade que a pessoa seu meio
de ou é humilde
ou ela é agressiva se ela for passiva
ela não presta ela é uma pessoa que na
verdade é o coitadinho ou a coitadinha e
na verdade quando a gente chama de
humildade nada quer é dizer a respeito
de autocondenação que está vinculado à
humilhação não tem nada a ver
mas como explicar isso uma criança de 5
anos e uma segunda o segundo aliás s
eu sempre tentei mostrar para o eso é a
respeito da felicidade quando a gente
para poder pensar o que é ser feliz é
algo realmente instigante
quem nunca se pegou pensando será que eu
sou feliz
ou será que eu tenho um momento feliz
qual é a diferença entre cnt e na
verdade para explicar isso pro enzo
muitas vezes eu me pego e acredito que
vários de vocês pensar o seguinte e se
um dia eu ganhasse na mega sena em roda
de amigos que nunca conversou a respeito
disso
geralmente nós pensamos
eu teria novos carros novas casas mas
raramente a gente pensa em compartilhar
em cd em ajudar o próximo em de alguma
forma transmitir isso há uma outra
sociedade é daqui a 15 dias o pessoal eu
faço 38 anos
na verdade nesse novo meu setênio e que
é são grandes estudos voltados para isso
a cada sete anos
entende-se que a gente tem uma
transformação do qual eu tenho passado
por ela eu tô na divisão entre razão e
entre a emoção ea e transmite isso pro
eso significa que felicidade pra mim é
que eu tenho limite para se chegar nessa
felicidade e que muitas vezes pensar em
grandes passos para frente pode não me
permite chegar naquele caminho que
desejaria
quando eu falo sobre a morte da
felicidade não quer dizer a morte física
da pessoa mas a morte de alguns sonhos a
morte de alguns momentos sejam aqueles
do qual por exemplo eu estou em uma
viagem numa cidade próxima a litorânea
do brasil e eu vejo na internet uma
outra pessoa numa viagem em miami
geralmente você fala poxa eu gostaria
muito de estar lá mas você acabou de
matar o seu momento de felicidade não
dando valor a importância daquele
momento que de certa forma você está
vivendo
então passando alguns ensinamentos para
o enzo é nítido que o que eu quero
passar pra ele de fato é que tudo acaba
quando eu falo acabar não quer seguir
não significa acabar não ser a morte não
é isso
eu também não estou dizendo aqui que nós
temos que é nos abstrair de ter as
coisas também não é isso
estou falando de viver o que na verdade
ou um simples fato de você comer uma
comida saborosa uma sobremesa
o segundo prato geralmente não têm o
mesmo gosto tudo literalmente passa e de
fato passa né
eu acredito que vários de vocês tem mais
de 20 anos e se eu perguntar o que
aconteceu com você nos últimos 5 10
talvez você não sei
é fato que tudo é mais rápido do que
imaginamos
os próprios corredores de provas de
velocidade que aproveitam os pouco menos
de 10 segundos sabe nos dizer muito bem
a respeito disso
aproveite cada segundo literalmente
e por fim a verdade é a melhor forma de
expressão então ser humilde e ser feliz
é ter a verdade consigo mesmo no mundo
hoje tão digitalizada muito fácil a
gente esquecer os valores da humildade e
da felicidade e sempre espelha no
próximo e não olhar para si mesmo e um
último recado que eu sempre passo por o
eso é que é necessário que todos nós
tenhamos o nosso limite
não adianta talvez hoje aqui eu não tô
falando que a palavra impossível poxa
você está negando impossível dotto
impossível só depende da nossa ação não
é esse mérito que eu tô entrando eu
estou entrada é curta jornada até você
chegar lá
se um dia você compra um carro que no
brasil hoje 20 mil reais você deseja um
de dois milhões
talvez vai ser bem complexo você fazer o
povo de 20 para 2 melhores mas curta
jornada até lá faça valer a pena essa
jornada e por fim essa imagem é de uma
cidade que é de montes claros nessa
cidade na verdade ela me ensinou
é uma coisa que felicidade e humildade
consegue andar juntos
eu gostaria de contar uma pequena
história pra vocês
no dia 25 de outubro do ano passado 25
de 2009 2018
eu estava com essa visão era mais ou
menos nove horas da manhã e às 9 horas
da manhã eu estava conversando com
grande parceiro que inclusive está aqui
hoje e veio um garoto à minha esquerda
o pedalando uma bicicleta e de certa
forma ele parou e falou eu poderia falar
com o senhor
eu olhei pro lado a primeira vez a
primeira coisa que eu fiz foi o
julgamento
eu mesmo tive humildade era um rapaz
extremamente sempre
do qual nós chamamos de como eu digo que
vinha bem magrinha
eu dava pra ele aí uns 12 13 anos eu
falei com ele não pode falar
meio que de forma arrogante ele falou
não o senhor pode terminar de conversar
vou te esperar
e aí eu terminei de conversar eu
perguntei pra ele assim o que você
deseja
ele fala é o seguinte como a nota de 2
reais na mão
eu tenho dois reais eu gostaria de
comprar comida
eu não estou aqui para poder pedir
dinheiro
eu falei ok mas o que você gostaria de
comer e ele falou pra mim qualquer coisa
naquele momento eu senti que eu tinha
que dar para aquele garoto algum sucesso
de direção há algum senso para que
eliminasse autocondenação ea humilhação
e transformá se a humildade dele não sei
e de certa forma eu perguntei pra ele
cara qualquer coisa não existe o que
você deseja
ele falou um prato de comida eu falei
'bom tarefa difícil ainda mais fácil
porque o prato de comida agora às 9
horas da manhã não vai ser possível
brincadeiras à parte eu tinha na minha
frente a um supermercado na padaria
na hora eu atirei eu falei pra ele assim
o negócio é o seguinte eu vou atravessar
a rua fazer uma copa pra você como é que
você vai levar ele falou o seguinte eu
amarro na bicicleta
eu falei na bicicleta não vai sentar
entender que nessa hora ele abriu um
sorriso que ele percebeu que talvez eu
ia comprar coisas que talvez ele não
teria tido a oportunidade de ganhar joga
esse meu colega atravessei a rua que
estava comigo me ligou e falou cara que
está fazendo eu falei que eu tô vendo
aqui fazer uma compra em fizemos uma
cobra e eu virei pregar outro emprego
desafio negócio é o seguinte melhor você
vai sair daqui agora vai procurar uma
pessoa que consiga levar isso pra você e
no momento que estava passando no caixa
ele né de um cesto de humildade para
quem sabe é leitura corporal de pegar a
camisa e passar no rosto com muito suor
eu descobri que ele estava vendo de um
local chamado industrial que tem tempo
não entendia e era relativamente longe
de onde ele estava ele foi de bicicleta
e naquele momento ele pode
pra mim assim falava assim eu consegui
eu consegui quem vai levar
ele espera aí e naquele momento é que eu
estava passando caixa ele olhou e falou
assim aqui tem vaga tio aqui tem vaga
falei não mas é educado porque era um
caixa de 10 a 12 volumes segundo momento
do riso fator de felicidade
ele fez a conta matemática mesmo às
vezes com 12 13 anos que talvez o volume
seria maior do que o esperado e no
momento em que eu estava colocando as
compras no carro ele no carrinho
eu perguntei pra ele você estuda ele
fosse estudantil é eu tenho 12 anos mas
eu tenho três irmãos e de vez em quando
eu tenho que vir aqui porque a situação
aperta
eu falei beleza é você vai levar mesmo
né falou 'não vou levar
eu saí e de certa forma naquele momento
é eu virei eu estava voltando dessa foto
vocês estão vendo a atravessar o hotel
olhei para o lado e mais uma vez eu
julguei porque ele no momento de
felicidade a bicicletinha dele e
ajeitando aquela pergunta do qual era
duas vezes maior do que ele de tão magra
esse garoto me tira os únicos dois reais
que ele tinha porque tinha uma pessoa
pedindo ajuda na porta do supermercado o
que ele fez ele entregou os dois reais
para aquela pessoa
então antes de qualquer momento a gente
se tornar um [ __ ]
o ensinamento que eu passo preso nós
temos que ser feliz
antes de ser feliz nós temos que ser
humildes e há de ser humilde
nós temos que selos e naquele dia aquele
garoto foi os pra mim muito obrigado